all right
so
uh
welcome to the
morning of the fourth day of the
workshop i'm delighted to introduce uh
our first speaker of the morning matt
thorpe who is uh will be talking to us
from
manchester or nearby
manchester and uh his topic is a
linearized optimal transport
yeah
i think thanks so much stan so actually
i'm in cambridge at the moment i'm
actually at the ini but um i guess
relatively speaking i'm much closer to
manchester united to berkeley um
yeah so i guess to start off thank you
very much for like the kind introduction
it's really nice to participate in this
workshop
um i'm sorry i can't be there in person
i'd really like to have come and visit
but i guess it just wasn't wasn't really
possible
okay so i went to tell you about some
work i did with that two of katie's
excellent students uh tanji and uh and
john g and um i'm bernie schmitz um i'm
actually sorry his affiliation is out of
date he's that's cursing him now
um
okay
okay so i guess this audience i don't
really need to motivate the brazenstein
distance i guess we all probably already
think it's great um
you know it's got nice sort of you know
well understood properties um so
theoretically um it has this sort of
lagrangian viewpoint which is often much
more reasonable for modeling than
compared to the um
the eulerian viewpoint
but i think we probably also all agree
that there are some sort of you know
drawbacks
okay so particularly it's quite
restrictive on the input so we had to
treat images or signals as probability
measures
it's computationally quite expensive
and of course we don't really have uh
sort of off-the-shelf data analysis
tools so for example if you wanted to do
something like pca or lda
i wouldn't really know how to do this in
the in the vassarstein space but of
course for the euclidean space you know
it's just you know i i don't even have
to think about it i can just use inbuilt
function from matlab and everything
everything works
okay so the the object of this talk is
to talk about a
unbalanced optimal transport metric
which somehow relaxes the assumptions
we're going to place on these inputs
and then we're going to linearize this
and this kind of allows us to um
apply this you know off-the-shelf data
analysis tools and we'll also make it
computationally much more feasible
okay so i'll just start off with me
maybe just a set notation talking about
the usual sort of razorstein distance
so of course we probably all know that
there's three different ways to define
the electronic distance so let's start
off with the monitor formulation where
we look for these optimal transfer maps
we have the kantoric formulation where
we look for these optimal transport
plans and then finally we have the
ability of renegade formulation where
we're looking at minimizing the kinetic
energy of a fluid
okay so i mean i'll be fairly relaxed
about the assumptions but
you know unless under fairly reasonable
assumptions all these three uh
formulations are equivalent so i can
sort of go between them as i like
okay so uh
if i sort of start off by manipulating
the neurobinary formulation i can
i can write this down okay just the
kinetic energy
um
of this fluid that's every time step
okay i can also recall that
if i want to have a gd stick between two
measures mutants new this is just given
by
pushing forward
mu by this map
at t star t where t t just a convex
combination of the optical transformer
between mu and nu and the identity
okay um
i can also recall that along the
gd6 if i fix a particle and look at how
this particle um
moves in this
viewpoint the velocity is constant
right so this just means that my
velocity of particle
um
okay my velocity along the trajectory
given by t star t right this is just
going to be equal to you know where i
end up minus where i started from what
this means is that i can
look at this the benefit formulation and
this time integral effectively
disappears so what i have is the kinetic
energy each time is equal to the kinetic
energy or at the at the start
okay so this is nice because we can now
write this position distance as just
being the l2 norm of the velocity
okay so this kind of gives us these the
formal romanian structure where we have
um
you know this uh the bottom line
distance is just given by the sort of
inner product
okay so
we can you can sort of take advantage of
this and define the logarithmic map of
um of the measure nu at the
at this the point in the manifold mu
that's just being the velocity field
okay so from the previous slide right
this means we can write the rosenstein
distance has just been the altering norm
of the logarithmic map
okay so this was kind of exploited by
diane and some of his
collaborators and they defined the
linear voltage line distance as just
being the l2
norm
between the logarithmic maps
okay so what they do is they fix the
reference points mu and then they define
the linear velocity distance between mu1
and v2 that's just being the logarithmic
maps um
okay at the point mu of mu1 minus log of
the map of our mu2 at the point mu in
the l2 knob so this picture here is just
kind of demonstrating what's going on so
what we would so this is our reference
point here mu sorry for the change of
notation between the the figure and the
um and the rest of the slides
because okay so the vast line distance
is this sort of red curve here and then
in the tangent manifolds this uh this
red line here is exactly the same length
that's the right curve and similarly the
uh the blue curve here is exactly the
same length blue curve here then the
approximation which then down and its
collaborators made is that the green
curve here which is exactly the
buzzerstein distance between a mutual
and uh
is approximately equal to the distance
in the tangent manifold which is this
green line right here
okay so if we define this sort of linear
embedding map which just being the
logarithmic map right we we now have a
way of approximating the weizenstein
distance as a euclidean node
oh yeah sure please
go ahead
so i can't make it can someone pass the
microphone
all right
okay so yeah very naive question so when
you define that linear washer scientist
and see minimize over meal
no so actually we just fix a a reference
point um so this can be i mean this
could be anything so of course
the best possible reference point okay
i see that point sorry uh there's a
subscript emil thank you so much
yeah no no problem
okay so this this slide is just kind of
summarizing um essentially what i said
before was it kind of staying out how we
actually kind of solved this problem in
your own practice so
the i mean there's a lot of sort of
attention that has gone into this sort
of synchron algorithm which allows us to
solve the kantor rich problem uh fairly
efficiently so one starts off by finding
these sort of optimal transport
maps
sorry plans um
okay fire something like the sync on
algorithm from this we can extract the
optimal transport maps
and do something like price entry
projection
once we have the the maps we can define
the velocity uh
vectors just being the map minus the
identity okay and so this gives us kind
of the road map we're going from from a
measure a new into the uh into the
tangent plane
okay so this this example is taken out
of that's one of diane's papers
um
i just kind of demonstrate you know that
we can still apply off-the-shelf data
analysis tools so they consisted
well at least two examples so the first
one is these sort of sets of um of cell
images
so they carry out this framework they
work out what the tangent vectors are
okay use this embedding into the optimal
transport space and then they could do
things like principal component analysis
so i think this actually is really quite
a nice um example because you can really
sort of see here that what the modes of
variation in these images are so for
example if we look at the top row so
this corresponds to the principal um
components um we can kind of see that if
you look on the left hand side if you
look on the right hand side well we we
start we have something that's quite big
on the left and something quite small on
the right
and maybe the third line is also quite
interesting that
we see
um definitely kind of the extreme
specifically the third principle
components we see mass is really
concentrated in the middle compared to
mass being concentrated on the on the
outside
okay you know and there's similar sorts
of things you know side and faces
okay this is the framework also allows
for uh
data points to be generated so the idea
here now is that we start off by
approximating this buzzer style manifold
at k different points
um
okay so let me just throw it okay so we
have like a set of images so ui
um we want to cluster these in decay
groups so actually we did this by
linearizing at one reference point and
then we just did k means
and this then gives us cluster centers
so we call the cluster centers new k and
these are the points which we're going
to approximate the stuff razerstein and
manifold
i'm at
okay so at each of these k centers we
again use the linear optimal transport
setting but now we just um
we just use the images which we're
associating to that cluster
um
okay and then we fit like a gaussian
model so you know we find the mean and
we find the covariance
okay so you know we know we we pick a
point
okay then we approximate this is the
tangent um when i follow with a gaussian
okay and this now means that we have a
distribution which we can draw from so
if we wanted to generate a new uh image
we would sample one of the points
and then we sample a tangent vector um
in that in that
in that tangent plane
okay and then we can create a new image
just by pushing forwards well just by
you know defining the transform map to
be the velocity vector plus the identity
okay this seemed to work quite well so
different applications so
i think one thing one can always ask in
these in these data generating
examples is are you really learning new
images or are you just sort of
getting back what you put what you put
in
so we did this on a very very small data
set so we just took 19 images so the 19
images we took on the uh
on the top row
and then we generated new images and
given that we only had 19 images i think
we did you know a fairly reasonable job
you sort of see that we don't
none of these new images
are exactly like one of the old images
it's not perfect you can see sometimes
the mouse gets a bit sort of messed up
but it's
it does a fairly nice job
okay so far this is all been on the on
the balanced optimal transport i've said
nothing about unbalanced optimal
transport
okay so to sort of talk about this let's
go back to the the continuity equation
okay so this is in the video bringing
formulation we were minimizing the
fluids subject to satisfying the
continuity equation so a natural way to
allow for balance measures is to allow
is to add a source of sink term
um
okay so we define the continuity
equation with source that's just being
we have our density rho our momentum
omega and now we have this zeta which
allows um from us to be created and
destroyed
the question now is well of course we
have to penalize other in some ways
otherwise you know you would never do
any transport you just do creation and
destruction so how you know what's kind
of the the right way to
to add the source term okay so perhaps
there isn't a right way but there's
maybe some ways i'm more natural than
others
so
this was proposed by several groups so
uh leonard actually spoke about this on
tuesday um he's one of the groups that
kind of proposed this to fall
independently um but this was also
proposed being more or less at the same
time by shazam schmitz uh
and eero mel k and savaray
so
the dates here i think correspond to the
when the papers are published actually
all these papers kind of came out i
think within like two or three months of
each other
um okay so they proposed um using the
cost function of this form here which is
you know related to like the fissure of
our
distance
okay of course i mean there's there's
other ways i think so i think i stand
the usher in his group they use like an
l1 penalty on zita and numerically you
know this is this is you know kind of a
nice thing to do as well it doesn't
quite have the same geodesic structures
um
which one gets when they use a penalty
of this this form here though
okay so this is the model which we're
going to use
so we defined the halogen contours
distance as just being the
minimization of all the contingent
equations with source of so here we have
kind of the western part then here we
have this this creation and destruction
and so for convenience i put a factor
about quarter here
i'm matching some of the numerics i show
later this quarter is going to become a
parameter lambda essentially it will
control the length scale over which we
decide we either want to transport or if
we want to uh creation and destruction
okay so from now on i'll talk about this
hello kantor resistance and the question
is can we have the same sort of
framework so can we do this
linearization um
yeah and how does that work
okay
so
which kind of starts off with the
bending robotic formulation of the
helmet and tortoise distance so the
question now is well is there a
kantorage farm and actually yes there is
a kentucky farm in fact there are
actually two cantara rich farms so i
think i'll just talk about one of them
here
so let me start off by
defining the callback level divergence
in in the usual way
okay i'll define this sort of cost
function which is now okay is it's maybe
a little bit strange compared to just
like the valentine cost function which
would just be x minus y
squared now i kind of you know i it's
minus log of cos squared of x minus y
and this is only when x minus y is less
than pi over 2.
so this so you can see immediately we
have like a threshold on how far we're
going to um
how far going to transport so if i want
to transport from x to y and x and y are
further than pi over two apart because
i'm going to play an infinite cost so i
can kind of see that my transport is is
limited
and this pi over two of course right
comes from uh i mean would change if you
change the factor back to here
okay so uh one can show that the this is
the benefit formulation is equivalent to
this soft uh marginal cantor rich
problem
so again so in the cantor in the sort of
einstein distance one would norm just
have the integral over
over the cost function um
okay where the cost function would be
the quadratic
norm
and then instead of penalizing
constraints one would say because the
the marginals have to be exactly you
know mu and exactly nu so here pi one
that's a p one of push forward pi this
is the first margin or pi and
p two
push for pi it's the second module so
now of course we're saying that we don't
have the mods don't have to agree
exactly they just have to be kind of
approximately
close to mu and nu where this sort of
approximation is measured in terms of
the carbohydrate divergence
okay and so the minimization here is
over all of measures
or positive measures not necessary
probability measures likewise there's no
assumption that mu and and newer
probability measures um
either they can be any any of the
positive measures
okay um
a lot of the nice properties the else
time distance or sort of um carry
through someone can charge this in theme
is actually a minimization minimum okay
and one can show further that
the optimal pi star is again is
supported on the graph of a transport
map
okay so
uh but this time
the the first marginal is not going to
exactly be mu so in the buzzer-steiner
case again one gets the identity cross t
star push forward immune now we have
this new tilde so the mutual that is the
first marginal um
of pi star and this isn't going to be
exactly equal to mu but again it should
be kind of close because we're
penalizing this module in the carbox
right okay so i i put kind of a warning
here because there's some kind of
terrible equations on the next slide
which
i mean at least for me these aren't
really very informative i wanted to show
them just to kind of say okay we do have
equations right we can kind of write
these sorts of things down um
even though i think you can't really uh
well at least i i don't look at them and
they don't seem particularly natural to
me
although there is actually quite a nice
sort of um way of understanding these
but i'd have this would take a little
bit of time to kind of explain
where they're coming from
okay
so what we have is we have
our inputs and nu which are just uh
positive measures
okay we'll have some pi star which is
optimum so again we can kind of use
something like the synchron algorithm
this will this will solve our
soft marginal plantar rich problem okay
then from that we have to extract our
optimal stuff you know mulch map t-star
okay and then i'll let my new tilde be
the first marginal and nutella to be the
second marginal
what i can do that then is i can
decompose the original measurement into
the parts okay which is absolutely
continuously respecting me tilde and
this singular part here
so approximately i can sort of
understand this as being this mutilate
is going to correspond to the transport
part and this
mu perp is going to correspond to the
correspond to the masters
and completely destroyed
okay and similarly
my my target measure new i can decompose
this into something that's absolutely
continuous with respect to my
uh respect to
uh my second marginal and something
that's singular so again this part here
the new tilde part this corresponds to
the
to the transport that's arriving um from
from mu and this new uh perp this
corresponds to mass that's going to be
created from from nothing
okay in that case one can write down the
um the gd6 so we have this road tilde
it's the road till that is is the
mass that's um transported
from uh from mu to uh nu so this of
course rate is a push forward of a
measure with respect to new tilde
okay so this capital m here is somehow
the the mass along the
gdc and this x is kind of the trajectory
so the directory is is a straight line
so it's just a is an
interpolation between okay if we for
moving from uh
from x naught to x one then it's you
know moving a straight line we don't
move a constant speed so the speed
itself depends on some some thigh which
is given in this form here
and likewise the mass along the uh the
transport
this again is well you can see here it
is essentially um quadratic
and between uh okay so we're moving mass
m naught from x naught to mass m one at
x one okay then you know it's off of
this form here
okay so this anyway corresponds to how
density sort of involves normal
transport and then we have the
density that corresponds to the pure
pure destruction and to pr creation yeah
so again i mean there's kind of just
okay these are probably just special
cases actually i've had
of the uh of where we tilde but when
okay so
[Music]
if if m1 is equal to zero okay we get uh
we get just this term here okay so you
can see we know our mass
so it is quadratically uh
increasing
it keeps the momentum so of course
momentum um is only going to be defined
over the transport okay and again it
takes this this form here
and the uh the creation of mass again we
can break this into two terms here so we
have the creation
uh the creation destruction along with
the transport and then we have the pure
the uh so yeah so the pure destruction
and the pure creation
okay so it's kind of important to know
right that we we don't we have pure
creation of destruction and we have
transport with creation and destruction
we don't have pure transport
so it'd be kind of nice so in in the
valentine case what we could kind of do
is say well let's just consider when
time t is equal to zero so we can
already say that that isn't going to
work
and that's because
this part here the part where we have
pure creation this is going to be
singular with respect to the the measure
that we started out with so we we know
we kind of can't guess you know this
this is the linear embedding in the same
way as before
okay in other words we can kind of do
something
so okay so
like before i'll set uh velocity okay
it's just the uh momentum over over at
mass
and then i have this term here alpha
which this corresponds to mass being
basically the mass being created and
destroyed on the transport and we've
included the
the pure destruction so there's no pure
creation here
and what we can okay so first of all we
can evaluate these formulas fairly
easily when when t is equal to zero
they're just you know given a given like
this
so of course when we're not transporting
anything velocity is zero um
[Music]
yeah and then we have nowhere
there's this velocity here um
where we are transporting and mass
creation and destruction so again if
we're
if we have a
pure absolutely
pure destruction then this alpha
knowledge is minus two and okay it takes
a slightly more complicated form when
when we're uh we're transporting as well
okay but if we
we if we sort of um we can rewrite the
hundred defensory distance now in terms
of something which only depends on um
[Music]
on at time t equals zero plus this i
guess this kind of annoying part which
is the the pure um
the pr creation
okay so this is almost exactly what we
want so you know we have a quadratic
sort of l2 term and then you know this
annoying touch variation parts we can
also kind of get rid of this
um a little bit essentially if we assume
that our measure mu
is kind of covers enough of the space um
and what we have is that the the thing
the um the pure
um
yeah the pure creation part is going to
be zero essentially so
we can't do pure creation if we already
have something there and actually we
don't even need to have something there
which i need to have something kind of
close enough to it um
okay so if we assume that you know the
support of mu is the whole space then we
have exactly the helen de cantora which
distance is
given sort of l2
too far
okay so this now allows us to kind of go
back and
essentially carry out the same
the same framework that dan did um
in his work so we defined the
logarithmic map to be the initial
velocity and this um
alpha which corresponds to the creation
of destruction okay and then of course
we can write the helium contour distance
just being the l2 norm of the um
you know very nice a very very formal
logarithmic map because of course we're
ignoring the new perp term
okay so we uh
we can define the linear
distance it's just been the difference
between the log from the maps in the l2
node okay and the embedding map this
being this this logarithmic map
okay and we make the same same
assumption right that the um the
helicopter contouring systems between
two points mu one and mu two this should
kind of know approximately equal to the
uh
distance in the l2 knob between the two
two projections
okay and the roadmap
is very similar to the
the previous map so we start off by
finding the optimal optimal transports
uh plans um
pi star
okay um
from so we use the sinkhole algorithm
for this we can extract the optimal
orange maps
and we define these you know the
densities you and w which are identities
with respect to the to the marginal side
mute tolerance and nutella
um
okay we evaluate the velocity maps and
this alpha term using the formulas in
the previous theorem okay and this all
gives us a way to go from a you know an
arbitrary positive measure to our
velocity and
mass destruction and creation
okay so i think the rest of it now is
just kind of there are some examples um
so we did this on a very tight problem
so
we have a data set which varies in two
different ways
so one of the ways it varies so the data
set is consists of two ellipses um so
each each data point is an image which
contains two ellipses so the yellow kind
of indicates where there's mass and
everywhere i'm not sure what color you
would call the background it's like blue
or purple and
this is where there's no mass
so the
ellipses are kind of either you know on
the sides or they're sort of
you know rotated round
um
[Music]
yeah and the other way that the uh
that these images vary is um
is the amount of mass
is is different um so she isn't quite so
clear in this in this figure but
the
um
i think like on this side here there's
there's more mass in the top one and
less mass in the bottom and then this
becomes more less mass here and more
mass must here
right so
if we do these projections in the
okay so first we'll do the bits in the
um
in the uh
razerstein space i mean we still get
these sort of natural sort of clusters
but they're kind of
more i guess
sporadic um
so here so after
i can't remember now
how about these so i think these lines
here indicate that the images so
these images have the same uh amount of
mass so each x here corresponds to one
image we've done the linear embedding in
the vasatine space and then we just
projected onto the two principal
components and then we've connected all
the points which have the same mass
um
okay and you know they are actually kind
of clustered together
if we do this in the halogen tolerance
space somehow i think this is kind of
gives them maybe like a nicer nicer
picture
because now this the variations in both
space are kind of much
um
well everything is much more uniform so
i think if we sort of look maybe at the
the columns
here right this is going to correspond
to the elongations and we can kind of
see that you know changing the mass and
changing the elongation it kind of gives
us the same sort of um
you know it's the same sort of i guess
clustering um whereas here if we change
the elongation um
you know we're going to jump to
completely different um
different parts of our pca space
and this is maybe more sort of evident
when we sort of look at the
anti-velocity fields
so in the razerstein um
distance
you can see here that the
we end up having mass moving from one of
the ellipses to the
to the other ellipse so here i think we
have have less mass we have more mass of
the masses moving from the top to the
bottom
um
we kind of see the same thing actually
in both of the razorstein modes so you
can see here we still have
mass moving between the two ellipses
yeah which is perhaps not not as sort of
physically not as nice
in terms of the halogen contour it's
distance right we get a really nice
separation so
[Music]
there's no first of all there's no mass
moving between the two ellipses
and secondly we can see so we can see
that the first sort of um principle
component mode this really corresponds
to you know the top lips being sort of
stretched out and the bottom
ellipse kind of being pushed pushed
together
here and in the second mode this
corresponds to the top
um to the first ellipse being to the
shrunk and then the second ellipse uh
sort of growing which are the exactly
the the two um
the two variations that we put into this
stage set
okay so slightly more realistic example
is this
jet tagging
her case
so
the data actually was was simulated but
it's kind of stimulated
to kind of it's closely represent what
one was to observe instead of particle
detectors like you know like the one at
cern for example
um
so
here we kind of at least my
understanding is that we sort of imagine
the these images as being sort of you
know
like a plate and then we're looking at
where particles hit this plate
um this kind of gives like a signature
and the question is okay what reaction
does that signature come from
so in particular we're looking at two
different types so these sort of w boson
jets um
and i guess you know yeah this is qcd
jets
yeah so okay so um
yeah i've plotted here's some sort of
examples of what we sort of see so
the qcd jets are in uh
are in green
so these i think tend to be sort of like
a singular uh particle surrounded by
sort of you know smaller particles
whereas the w boson jets these tend to
be sort of two
two particles but surrounded by still
surrounded by lots of smaller particles
okay so kind of represent these as
images you know we can carry out our
sort of you know linear embedding
framework
and okay we can just deposit off the
shelf you know data analysis tools
so here we've kind of plotted the so
here we plotted the wasserstein distance
um
when we um okay so this is the
razerstein embedding
when we project onto the
onto the lda
axes
you can kind of see we don't really get
to the great separation between to the
green here towards the green so the
green was the qcd jets
and the red was the uh
the jets the uh w boson jets and we
don't get a particularly great sort of
separation in classes okay so for the
hell energy contouring distance we do
essentially do better
so we plotted it here for a range of
different scales so if you recall when i
first introduced the 100 torx systems we
had this factor of a quarter in front of
the mass creation and mass destruction
term one can replace that quarter and
put the capper and this kind of controls
the length scale
and so we kind of played around the
length scale a little bit
but since you can see that you know we
do get because it's not perfect there's
overlap between the two
between the two projections onto the um
lda axes but we do essentially do better
and actually if we plot the
plot the first two principal components
of the data you can kind of see that we
are getting us you know well we're
certainly getting linear separation but
we are sort of getting you know
separation well things seem to be
natural to clustering together you can
kind of see that once the class sort of
you know behaviors like you know like
this and then okay most of our um
so i think this is the qcd jets right
now sort of concentrated around here
um
it's also kind of interesting to note
that
where we kind of i guess do badly
actually it's kind of reasonable
so if we follow this sort of
this trajectory here
we can sort of see okay so one two and
three these are all the w boson jets and
yeah we can still see you know we have
kind of two
sort of quite big particles surrounded
by small particles then as we go into
the um
interpreting the green region okay we
really have kind of one particle um
derived by small particles then over
here where they're technically you know
uh
back to the f but again what it's to the
uh w boson jets
actually we still have like one particle
here so it perhaps it's understandable
that we're kind of getting this this um
you know that
we're separating these these ones out
okay so of course you know we did some
sort of you know
off-the-shelf sort of labeling i'm using
lda k n and um support vector machines
and the conclusions uh you know that's
the halogen cantor rich distance
essentially you know it does
does the best and
what sort of scale you want to use kind
of depends on how you want to measure
accuracy so we could
area under the curve and this is the
true positive rate false positive rate
um
yeah but the conclusions are that you
know the best results are always sort of
for the huntington tourist distance and
that's sort of scale you know between
sort of you know um well i guess 0.5 and
0.1
okay so
actually my talk is essentially done so
i have some sort of references
the papers that i kind of talked about
mostly um
well first of all this was the paper
where we generated new data uh using the
razerstein embedding um linearization
and then this uh second paper here this
is where we did the uh the linearization
of the helium check and torres distance
and these um
applications to
to uh jet tagging
so okay so with that thank you very much
for your attention and yeah any
questions
questions
and so my question is you know the
linearized
transport
distance the vases time one
is like
you know it's the an estimation from
above right of the real vast vassastine
distance
uh
what about the hellinger kantor which
one is it still
an estimate from above so you have an
inequality or
uh
you know that there is some asymptotics
i don't know
yeah exactly so i mean okay so
it should be an approximation in a very
formal sense so
i mean there's not very much theory
around i mean as far as i'm aware
there's no theory around how good this
approximation is for the hundred
contouring distance there is some theory
around how good this approximation is
for the weizenstein distance um i can't
remember the references off the top of
my head but people i know i have kind of
looked at this i think the question is
still kind of largely open from my
understanding but there at least there
are kind of some some bounds here which
kind of quantify how close they are and
of course it depends on how curved you
know your
you know the the vaseline manifold is
yeah in terms of like the how to control
edge approximation um
yeah i mean as far as where
and i'd be surprised if anyone's
actually so far has actually managed to
kind of quantify this
um so i'm not aware of anything
i mean this is also against like the
distance in the tangent manifold so this
should be a um
okay i think that way it's not a lower
bound or an upper bounds but it's um
it should but it should bound it from
from one way um
i guess it's probably a um
uh
it's probably a lower bounce but it's
it's it's after five o'clock here and um
my
i'm too tired to kind of think about
which
exactly uh
exactly which way it is but yeah in
terms of the upper band i think there's
nothing while you say that i know i've
nothing
thanks
thank you matt for very very interesting
inspiring talk this is this is really
easy
can you hear me okay
yeah
uh this um possibility of doing uh
principal component analysis in in the
space of distributions a very very
interesting direction
and i'm i'm been wondering you know if i
understand correctly uh so doing this in
the tangent space and having this
linearized distance
a many things depend on the choice of mu
right
do you optimize
on that later on you showed um
two principal components
it it looks like it might be quite
critical how
what choices are made
yeah yes okay this is a very good
question um
so
i mean so first of all we haven't really
done anything proper optimization i mean
in theory i guess the optimals the mute
should be the barycenter um
what we've actually found in experiments
is that it doesn't really seem to matter
we can actually be fairly
lazy and just sort of pick almost
anything that seems to work fairly well
which is a little bit surprising but
yeah i agree i mean like in the um
i mean it's this uh it's my
representation of all my
points now if i pick my sort of you know
my cluster center is somehow you know
right over
here okay so i guess the center is
always going to be at uh
at zero but if i kind of shift this i
would expect the results to be quite bad
um
but it seems like it doesn't really
matter if you just choose for example
choose the first image to be your center
if you just choose um
like a euclidean average so i think when
diane did this he didn't use the the
razerstein barry center he used like the
euclidean barry center and again that
seemed to work so quite well um
so it seems like maybe
the space is fairly flat
where you kind of care about it but this
of course is just kind of what we
empirically
observe
it would be probably a bit more
difficult the space that's being very
curved in the
neighborhood of the densities that
you're looking
like for example if the body center is
way off from
yeah exactly exactly i mean i agree i
think as long as you choose
a center that's kind of you know roughly
sensible you seem to okay so i mean
actually i think yeah so in our case we
actually don't even choose something
that's particularly that sensible this
is our reference image it's just a
uniform um
measure over over the whole space and
can the reason why we used to do this is
well
it's because we want this condition uh
exactly this condition here we want the
supports of mu to kind of cover
everything um
yeah
yeah i guess it's a trade-off between
choosing a good center and um
you know if we don't use a center which
spans the whole space then we kind of
lose something in the um
you know we'd have to account for the uh
this this term here somehow
yeah thanks so yeah in our experience
just to comment briefly and actually
experience the
source measure right the the following
features were advantageous right that
it's uh at least as smooth as the
measures that you're trying to represent
so that it can represent somehow the
information they have i mean if you took
some measure that
only has few delta masses right into two
go to extreme right then a lot of
information is lost right and also that
okay a lot of the measures you know with
these phases and cells they had similar
support right so
it also is there is this requirement
that or you know it's advantageous if
the source measure would have similar
support right again that it represents
that part of the space
like all of these other measures but
that's just purely empirical again
right
so
i was curious if you
wanted to linearize your manifold not
only about one measure but you choose
say two three four points and represent
the data
as the with a logarithm at those points
do you think that that could give you a
better
representation
that good could give you better
clustering
um yeah it's interesting i guess this is
kind of what we did um
with the yeah in this data generating to
the example that um i guess the problem
you should have if you want to do sort
of clustering um is that how do you
compare points on different tangent
planes right they're not kind of
directly applicable and somehow i mean i
guess if you want to do clustering then
you probably already done the clustering
to kind of approximate them locally
around uh each point anyway
um
so yeah i'm not i mean whether or not
one can look at maybe doing this sort of
um
yeah approximating it to several
different points on the manifold and
then comparing you know
all of these but this kind of brings us
back to the sort of
what's a good cluster sensor problem and
it seems like we're not really very
sensitive to the cluster sensor so in
that sense i don't think there's
probably a huge amount to gain but
with the caveat that's yeah if you're
trying to do data generating it it
seemed to work a lot better to do this
sort of local approximation like we did
here
yeah thanks matt so uh
it's time for us to to move on so we'll
stop uh here with the questions but uh
let's thank uh again matt for this uh
intriguing talk
[Applause]
thank you very much everyone